all right welcome to another video today
we have justin khan as a guest
so justin khan is an entrepreneur
investor and recently
a content creator he founded multiple
startups like kiko socialcam
atrium but most of you know him as the
co-founder of twitch which got acquired
by amazon
for 970 million dollars
as an investor he was a partner at y
combinator investing and mentoring new
startups in the valley
today he has a fund called goat capital
with
robin chan oh and by the way let me know
if you want a new partner for your fun
i don't want to flaunt my wealth but i
have about 20 large already on a joma
capital so
all right we'll take it really okay
great
he recently started a tick tock and a
youtube channel that is doing extremely
well
inspiring people to start their journey
as founder so
welcome justin khan thanks for coming
doma welcome bye
welcome back you're inviting me but
thank you thank you for having me
awesome great so i just first wanted to
ask you like
you know what what's up with the the
youtube channel you know for a guy who
can be working
on anything like why why youtube yeah so
i guess it's specifically because i get
to be working on anything
that i love youtube it's been really fun
for me to flex my content creation
muscles and try to create my own brand
of
edutainment i'm loving it and having a
lot of fun with it
nice that's awesome so like what's your
what's your main goal
with the youtube channel when people
watch your channel what do you want them
to get out of it
i love just teaching people things so
some of the things that i'm most proud
of in my career is just
the times when i've been able to help
someone out give them some advice
whatever it is and
that's what i want to do at scale
through my youtube i had
someone come up to me at conference a
year ago
maybe a year and a half ago before the
pandemic and he gave me a hug and he was
just like you know justin
you talked about seeing a therapist and
now i'm seeing a therapist's founder at
a conference
and so it's just moments like that that
have really made me feel like i'm
contributing to the world in some small
way
and just trying to do more of that yeah
that's really that's really nice
um when did you start uh seeing a
therapist is it after twitch or before
twitch acquisition
it's kind of before so i was working on
this other company i was incubating uh
those
i was creating called exec and it wasn't
going really well
and i just was super depressed about it
out of desperation i went to see a
therapist and i was just like what's
wrong with me why can't i
why can't i do anything why am i not
motivated to do anything
the company wasn't doing well and i had
tied my ego up in the company you know
so i told all my friends i told our
investors
my employees this is going to be the
biggest thing ever and i'm i really have
wrapped my identity up as a
being a successful founder and so when
the company was not successful
that's that really was a blow to me and
i spent all of my time
instead of being in the present in this
present moment i spent all my time in
the past
thinking oh i should have started a
different company i should never have
started this company i should have done
something different
or i was spending time in my future like
how am i going to talk to my investors
about how this isn't working out or
you know i was just i was just always
caught in in
ruminating about the future or or
feeling sorry for myself about the past
it was just easy to forget the great you
know the the
what was good about my circumstances and
just be caught into this
negative feedback loop and so for me
it's like yeah i was had the successful
other company that my friend was running
but then this company that i really
cared about today wasn't working and so
it was easy for me to get to forget
about that other
side of things so i actually brought you
here to
because i want to quiz you on twitch all
right i want to know how much
the twitch co-founder actually knows
about twitch culture
so i'm going to ask you a series of
questions throughout this interview
and if you get more than half of them
right you'll get a prize
and then each time you get one wrong i
get to pitch you a startup
how's that okay all right all right this
is gonna be embarrassing
no i think i think you'll do pretty well
i think you do pretty well all right
so i even prepared a powerpoint for this
oh yeah so i actually made a whole
presentation on our merger but
we can i like it
um okay
so first question
what does poggers mean
poggers is like oh [ __ ]
it's like when you're excited about
something right yeah yeah yeah excellent
oh okay i think that's really good yeah
it's when you're excited about something
like this poggers yeah yeah
nice congrats all right that was an easy
one we'll we'll do something a little
bit more difficult
what is that the name of this emote
kappa i know that one because that guy
used to work for me
oh really yeah so so what happened is
funny story josh
this who is this guy uh was a programmer
he was like a young guy who's
working at twitch as a programmer and in
the early days
before we've been pivoted to twitch and
we used to put all the
founders and early employees in the chat
as emotes so if you type in
jcon style right now into twitch my face
will pop
up from 12 years ago or you know 15
years ago or whatever it was
um but we stopped doing that after we
hit like eight employees right because
it was just too many emotes and then
eventually josh took over the chat code
and he saw this code base and he just
added himself
most of the you know hot keys or like
that the text that people would
that were was representative of each of
us was like much longer
you know but he he made his kappa
because that was like his nickname it's
very short
and i think because it was short people
started using it
a lot and so that's how it became
popular
all right so the next question is
what does no cap mean i have a feeling
you won't get this one
well i mean no cap in other context
means like i'm not lying
but like because i assume is that what
it means on twitch yeah
yeah that's what it means okay well i
guess you got that too oh [ __ ]
yeah for some reason i i thought you
would get these wrong so i could pitch
you startups but i guess not
you can pitch me to start up anyway it's
okay all right
speaking of like startups let's go back
to startup questions um
yeah you when you talked about exec uh
you then actually mentioned
what exec was about was an errand
running service it was like a live air
running service and you could just
it's kind of like uber meets taskrabbit
you just put in whatever you want into
this
text box and then we would try to
deliver to you but eventually
that idea didn't really work and so we
turned it into something that was more
like
a cleaning service like an on-demand
cleaning service which
was a terrible business well they were
like during the time when we were
working on exec everybody was
all these venture capital you know
funded companies were
scaling these businesses with extremely
low margins that they were giving
basically giving away money to users
if you were going to start a company
today i wouldn't start a cleaning
company yeah
i get i would start something like
twitch i think you know
if i had to choose twitch if
yeah so why did you think uh twitch
succeeded then like
when you worked there yeah you know in
the beginning well i think what really
worked is my co-founder emmett
identified that gamers were what we
wanted to focus on and kevin lynn who is
uh our ceo they went to gamers and asked
them like what can we do to make
you stream on twitch what can we do to
make your experience better
and so they spent a lot of time doing
that and just really creating that
tight feedback cycle with the customers
and talking to the customers
was huge that's what made them um
that was what made them come and stick
and really feel like they were listened
to
you know your customers want to be loved
and they want to feel like you care
about them and so
if you listen to them that's a really
great way to show you that you care i'm
guessing that you guys had like an
exponential
growth right because it's such a good
product it started it started
multiplying in users
it grew really quickly once we pivoted
from justin tv to twitch
uh justin d was our first company that
was kind of like this live streaming
company
uh for anything and we turned it into
twitch you know as soon as we started
working on twitch it kind of grew and
grew and grew very consistently but
it wasn't exponential you know it was it
was kind
of it was with fits and starts you know
it would like grow some and then would
stop and grow and because we were very
dependent on live events
some months where there would be like
really big live events it could be
really big and then other months it
might
not be as big so when you have these
huge big events did you ever run into
like scalability issues
infrastructure wise or people-wise
i mean anybody who's knows who's been on
twitch knows that we ran into a lot of
scalability issues so i'm not gonna lie
we did a lot with a small team though we
built this uh
you know data set data centers and like
streaming
uh points of presence like all over the
world 16 locations
with a team of like less than four on
the network engineering side so we we
scaled quite a bit
but you know it was still there was
still some occasional
downtime so when you started um twitch
or
justin tv you said that um you weren't
really a great programmer
right yeah i was not a good programmer
when we started justin tv
so what but i learned to be a decent one
i was
i'm a really good catalyzer of people
i'm really good at getting people
excited
about an idea and getting together and
executing on that idea
how how did you get that skill do you
think it was just um
you were born with it you know i've i
guess i've always i've always been
excited about new ideas and i can't help
but evangelize them and so
i think that's been a big part of it to
be honest
so your weakest asset like would you say
programming was your weakest asset
compared to the other co-founders
no no no my my well i was much worse as
a programmer than
the other co-founders for sure but i
think my weakest
you know skill that i probably would
have benefited me to be good at was
on the management side you know i was a
pretty weak manager in the
in the beginning because i i didn't have
any experience we started the company
before we
had ever really had a job in the real
world so
what are some tips and tricks to
becoming a better manager
what have you learned okay the basics
right you gotta talk to that your
team members regularly you have to
regularly schedule one-on-ones like that
took me years to figure out
and then it's like you need to
write down feedback and tell people
feedback and
ask for feedback right like it's like
people are scared to get feedback i was
so scared to give people feedback
because i thought they'd be offended
they'd like run away they quit
their job and so for me that like just
the
realizing feedback's a gift and i need
to invest in in giving people feedback
was a
was a big part of it those seem like
really basic things but you know if
you're a new manager they're like
you know they were those are those are
gems uh one of the biggest things
the books that was really instrumental
for me is this book called high output
management by andy grove
and anybody who has been in silicon
valley long enough has been
you know affected by the lessons of it
because it's kind of a bible here in
silicon valley but
it's a great handbook for any new
manager so i was wondering
if you have to tell my viewers like a
few tips
and like how to start a startup or
just the way to start a startup like
what tip would you give them
well the first thing is just get started
you know like a lot of people have it in
their own mind they're like
oh i can't do this because it's too hard
i don't know how to do it i
like i don't know where to start like
the first step is the hardest
you know if you're building some sort of
app or website like anybody can learn
the skills to do that now
you know it's very accessible and so you
don't have to be a genius programmer to
do it you can just get
started like the way i taught myself to
build my first website is i was just
googling tutorials on building websites
online you know and so i think getting
started is the first step
and the second thing i'd say is like
work on something that you care about
you know i think it's so important to
work on something where you would work
on it even if you weren't getting paid
you know because that's what's going to
that passion and it's going to what's
going to drive you
when things are tough and it's going to
make you stick with it
and so i think a lot of people choose
what to work on based on what's going to
make the most money or because
you know they're very mercenary about it
but i think it's so important to work on
something you actually give a [ __ ] about
when do you get in the zone like what
what's
what's passion for you yeah so i mean
when i'm making content
i think for me i'm often in the zone and
that's why i like it so much
you know i love to just brainstorm ideas
and write and
then film like that's what i like doing
so to me that's like it's like a hobby
and i'm not getting paid because my
youtube channel only has you know
20 000 subscribers or whatever but uh
you know
maybe one day i will but it doesn't
matter to me and i think that's why i
like it so much
i think by the time i release this video
it might be like a hundred thousand i
think
all right my youtube video i'll
re-record that my youtube channel only
has
500 000 subscribers so i'm not getting
paid but
you know maybe one day i will i'm pretty
sure you get paid at 500 000 subscribers
but yeah
all right let's take a break and we'll
come back with more quizzes
yeah so these breaks are actually
perfect for me to put ad breaks
so that's actually for me
oh i actually have a a funny thing i
forgot to ask
uh yeah so before we go to the quizzes
um
i heard that during your senior year at
yale
you posed for a charity calendar you
created
and like is that is that you
oh that is i'm very proud
i'm proud of it that that one's cut out
there's like you know the original has
i'm in like a the kitchen of our
uh kind of dorm room or dorm house the
house that we lived in
in college and uh yeah that's me it was
it was it's uh it's very impressive
thank you the story behind that is that
at lunch just then when i was talking to
him on the phone i was like okay i'm
gonna make this calendar i started
talking to some people who were like
sitting next to me about it
and i was convincing them to pose for it
and i said
you know to convince him i said i'll do
something more ridiculous
than whatever you do like if i'm asking
you to like
rub rose puzzles on yourself in the
shower i'm gonna
i'm gonna do something even more
ridiculous and so
they see that they agreed and i got
friends of mine to like one of my
friends was literally rubbing soap on
him in the shower myself in the shower
one was like
lying on the pool table covered with
rose petals and so i had to go you know
i had to make good on my word and do
something that was just
even even more extreme that is crazy
were you
were you always this ripped i mean to be
honest i looked a lot better
than that last year but then i got into
this
yeah i've been i was you know working
out pretty heavily
for the last couple years and then then
i got into this accident and broke both
my elbows so my workouts have gotten a
little bit weaker
yeah but you know i'll always have this
photo right that's the important part
that's pretty cool
i mean i also have a more recent picture
of you uh
i think it's this one so this is what
you look like now right
this is that's my body yes that's very
nice very nice
but yeah okay let's go to the quizzes
now um okay these ones are actually
harder like you might you have to watch
a video and stuff you just have to watch
like five seconds of it
and then you have to tell me what this
streamer is talking about
it's continuing to load you know for
for someone who sold his company for 970
million you kind of have
pretty slow internet slow my internet's
fast it's my computer
it's like a slow piece of [ __ ] which is
weird because it's like a
mac you know like top of the line
macbook like
maybe have too many tabs open uh that's
weird
there's a risk for reward right and even
even the mages like orion definitely
feels like
right but lux players oh no
no oh no no guys no no
is this guy like cosplaying something
he's like doing ninja stars
[Music]
kaido for people who who
who understands it it makes complete
sense
i don't know what's going on
[Laughter]
oh my god he's no now he's shooting up
an airport
oh that's a different club i feel like
that's a different club now
all right so i'm guessing you have no
idea finally
no i have no idea right so he was um he
was talking about league of legends
yeah yeah he was talking about how this
character is so cheap and doesn't take
any skills playing it because it you
just do fuchi
okay i i dude i never played league
oh really even though it was like one of
our most popular games
did you play any video games yeah i
played hearthstone
oh like a nerd intellectual game of
course whatever
anything and i played i used to play
call of duty like
10 years ago oh okay fps nice nice do
you know about the game valorent
no nah it's it's the newest fps shooter
it's it's made by riot games but anyways
oh
excellent i could pitch you a startup
all right okay all right let's see which
one should i choose let me look at my
list
okay this one's actually pretty good i
think like it's a real one
so it would be imdb or linkedin but for
youtubers
so youtubers can hire like editors
videographers thumbnail designer
you'll have a bunch of youtubers profile
and you have a bunch of like editors
profile and you could
have like you know which editor has
worked with which
uh youtubers right away or you could
click on a certain video that they've
made and you could see
who worked on it so you can hire people
who are already
in the industry or like the youtube
industry that's interesting
that's not a bad idea yeah i wonder why
that
hasn't existed for normal film and tv
production
oh it does it's called imdb but do
people hire people off imdb
um yeah that's a good question i'm not
really in the industry but
i think they do look at they have to
they have to download oh sorry they have
to pay for imdb pro
to actually see the whole cast list and
then i'm guessing that's what they do
yeah
that's actually not a bad idea i feel
like it
it could work the you know because
there's so much
this like like i said on the influencer
economy side it's becoming the whole
economy like youtube pays out what 10
billion dollars to creators every year
or something yeah
i mean it's a huge industry now so i
don't know
yeah i can see it not bad right not bad
all right cool
all right let's go to another question
what is the name of this emote
uh i don't know that's a pepe the frog
right yeah oh you got that right
like this one yeah to call it you have
to write feels bad man which is why
oh yes feels bad man it's sad all right
one more startup okay let's see social
media
for youtubers with 100k subscribers plus
anyone below it they can't join it so
it's more exclusive
oh wait so you can't join it oh
dude it's cold that's cold but i have
500 000 subs now by the time this video
is i really hope you don't
joke works um that would be cool it's
kind of like a
uh like a exclusive social network like
raya
what's raya it's that like dating app
that you have to be you know like get
approved to join or whatever
right i think i think there was another
one called something else called
it was called elites or something i
don't remember what it was but
i think i got approved yeah yeah nice
nice work
yeah you're in the elite now it was
pretty easy i think they accepted like
hundreds of thousands of people by then
but yeah
all right cool and then the last
question is
at this moment right now which category
has the most viewers
kind of assuming it's like just chatting
or fortnight
oh my god you got it right again well i
think i don't know it was it was just
chatting an hour ago let's let's see if
it changed
twitch
[Music]
oh yes twitch just chatting with 343 000
viewers yay
hooray it would look less awkward with
the editing so
yeah all right
i'm not i didn't fully embarrass myself
no i don't think so i think you did
really well to be honest you almost
i think you almost got every question
right except for like two
anyway so the prize is you have won
a 25 amazon gift card
uh it says 50 here but it's just like a
stock image
but it's it's 25.
i'm gonna buy myself some camera
equipment yeah i don't think you can buy
anything with 25
to be honest i could buy like uh uh what
is it one of those quick release plates
for my camera
to fit on my tripod oh okay yeah i mean
the expensive ones are a little bit
like fit more expensive but yeah i guess
you could buy a cheap one
um oh [ __ ] you're shading me and my
camera purchases
yeah all right but yeah it's pretty
crazy right it's like history repeats
itself you know first amazon
pays you 970 million and now they're
paying you 25
it's crazy i love it yeah yeah actually
you're paying them to pay me 25
yeah that's true that's true cool cool
all right um yeah i think that's pretty
much it well
you know thanks for coming justin
awesome
yeah thanks for having me this is so
much fun yeah i'm glad you enjoyed it
and i'm glad
you got the quizzes right yeah all right
all right i didn't look terrible